jean gérard larcher on a donné le
calendrier il ya quelques heures
aujourd'hui en début d'après midi à la
conférence des présidents
il présentera une proposition de
résolution début juin ensuite elle sera
votée vraisemblablement vers le 23 juin
donc en conférence des présidents avant
et le 23 juin sans doute en séance ce
qui permettra de lancer la commission
denquête à la fin du mois de juin
donc quand j'espère on sera un peu
décalée de l'épidémie notre objet à nous
c'était de sortir du pic épidémique pour
qu'on puisse lancer cette commission
denquête dont l'objectif n'est pas du
tout de régler des comptes politiquement
mais dont l'objectif est de faire le
point sur les forces et surtout sur les
faiblesses de la gestion de cette crise
pour que l'on puisse mieux armé demain
la france à faire face à d'autres
pandémies qui ne manqueront pas de venir
vraisemblablement